uh your Excellency the Europe European
commission president Ursula Wonderland
the honored members of the European
commission and Philippine delegations
members of the Malacca young press Corps
ladies and gentlemen
good morning
Madame Wonderland and I concluded a
successful and productive bilateral
meeting this is the first to visit to
the country by the president of the
European Commission
but during our meeting we discussed
economic relations with particular focus
and revitalizing trade between our two
regions I welcome the conduct of this
year of the scoping exercises between
the European commission and the
Philippines towards negotiations for a
Philippines EU Free Trade Agreement
the Philippine government experts will
work with the European Commission in
achieving a bilateral FTA
on development cooperation we committed
to conclude a financing agreement on the
green economy program in the Philippines
a grant worth 60 million Euros which
aims to support the Philippines in areas
such as circular economy renewable
energy and climate change mitigation
I likewise acknowledge that I EU staunch
support for the bangsamoro peace process
as well as the development of the
country in areas such as such as rule of
law Injustice agriculture space
cooperation and disaster management
I also thank the European commission for
their decision to extend the recognition
of the stcw certificates issued by the
Philippines as this has a positive
impact on the employment of more than 50
000 Filipino seafarers working on board
EU flag vessels
as I mentioned to Madame President Van
Der leyen the Philippines and EU are
like-minded Partners through our shared
values of democracy sustainable and
inclusive Prosperity the rule of law
peace and stability and human rights
the continued exchanges between Her
Excellency and myself which started in
Brussels last year is a testament to our
joint desire to bring our bilateral
relationship to Greater Heights let this
be a A New Beginning for the
strengthening and the deepening of all
our ties with the EU and the Philippines
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much
for welcoming me here in the Philippines
indeed it is the very first time that a
European Union commission president is
visiting the Philippines at this on the
eve of the 60th anniversary of our
diplomatic relations and I was glad to
meet you in Brussels at the end of last
year for our very successful EU asean
Summit
today I'm here to accelerate a new era
of cooperation between us
we share so many values and interests we
both want to work towards strengthening
our democracies we believe in the
international rules-based order and we
believe in the need to promote and to
defend it so it makes sense to
strengthen our ties across the board
and we discover discussed several ways
to do so
first by taking our trade relations to
the next level
the European Union is already your
fourth largest trading partner
and we are the first foreign investor
but we can do so much more
so I'm very glad that we have decided to
relaunch negotiations for a free trade
agreement
our teams will get to work right now on
setting the right conditions
so that we can get back to the
negotiations a Free Trade Agreement has
huge potential for both of us in terms
of growth and in terms of jobs
whether it is on the European continent
or here in Southeast Asia
we have all learned the hard way the
cost of economic dependencies we need to
diversify our supply lines and make them
resilient
and this is a lesson we have learned and
that is what we call de-risking our
trade relations
and FDA is the basis for that but it's
also much more and FDA can be a
springboard
for a new technology corporation to
modernize the broader economy
second element we discussed is the fight
against climate change
I welcome your ambition to put the
Philippines on the path to a cleaner and
Greener future we have the same ambition
therefore we created in the European
Union global gateway
global gateway is the eu's investment
plan for the world for sustainable
infrastructure
we want to partner with you on this path
notably with the team Europe initiative
on the green economy that we just signed
here
we will provide financing expertise and
access to Technologies
to support you in the transition to a
circular economy and the generation of
green energy
team Europe that is the European Union
and the member states will contribute
almost half a billion euros into this
green initiative
the European Union is also supporting
your fight against climate change and
extreme weather events with its
so-called eyes in the sky
this is the Copernicus satellites
we're currently setting up a so-called
Copernicus data mirror site within the
Philippines space agency
and we have just signed an agreement to
boost the flow on Earth observation data
between us this is very important for
early warning for example for extreme
weather phenomenons and to improve the
climate resilience
this is a first in-space Corporation in
Asia
my third point is on turning the
Philippines into a digital Hub in the
region
global gateway will also play a crucial
role role here
and European companies are ready to come
and invest in the Philippines
we will launch this year the digital
economy package for the Philippines that
is we will work together on fast and
reliable connectivity with submarine
cables on cyber security training and on
deployment and development of 5G
we are also working on a possible
extension on a submarine cable that we
plan to build between the European via
the Arctic to Japan and this cable could
go all the way down to Southeast Asia
and we believe that it could go via the
Philippines that would give you a
strategic position on an infrastructure
that could be instrumental both for your
prosperity and National Security we will
stay in close contact on this
my first point is on critical raw
materials
we need them for our clean and digital
future
here to the Philippines Philippines have
a great potential
and we want to work in partnership with
you
so let us start by identifying projects
that we would develop your local mining
industry supporting your communities
and that contributes to a secure Global
Supply of critical raw materials
our existing Partnerships on critical
raw materials do not only invest in
extraction but across the whole value
chain We Share technology and knowledge
we train the local Workforce and we
Empower local communities and of course
we abide by the highest environmental
standards
my final point is on cooperating on
security
the global geopolitical landscape is
changing it is volatile it is more
threatening
authoritarian leaders show that they are
willing to act on their threats
Russia's war of aggression against
Ukraine shakes the foundation of the
international order
it is in violation of the U.N Charter
and the fundamental principles of
international law such as territorial
integrity and sovereignty
and this is why Europe supports
Ukraine's Brave fight Brave fight
against the aggressor
because the illegal use of force cannot
be tolerated not in Ukraine not in the
indo-pacific
Security in Europe and Security in the
indo-pacific is indivisible
challenges to the rules-based order in
our interconnected World affect all of
us
our societies pay through higher energy
bills through higher food costs this is
why we are concerned about the rising
tensions in the indo-pacific
the European Union has been very
supportive of a free and open Indus
indo-pacific because an indo-pacific
free of the threats of coercion is key
to all our stability to our peace and to
the prosperity of our people
the European Union underlines that the
2016 Award of the arbitral tribunal on
the South China Sea is legally binding
and that it provides the basis for
peaceful resolving disputes between the
parties
we are ready to strengthen the
cooperation with the Philippines on
Maritime Security in the region by
sharing information
conducting threat assessment and
building the capacity of your National
coastwatch Center and your Coast Guard
to conclude we have a broad roadmap
to bring our partnership to the next
level let's use the great momentum we
have in our relationship and many things
for hosting this year thank you
thank you